MALE SPEAKER: Please welcome
Laura along with her guests.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS:
Welcome to our talk today.
Go to the next slide here.
So I first wanted
to thank Making
Science, the Google
Making Science team,
for hosting us today.
They have been
very helpful today
and in a lot of our
conversations too,
so I just wanted
to thank you all.
OK, so I'm going
to show you here,
this is an outline of our talk.
And you can see it will
ignite with some information
about the initial
collaboration that we've had,
and then talk about
our different missions
for our different
education efforts.
We'll talk about science,
the science universe, as well
as the indigenous, or Navajo
universe specifically.
We'll also then talk about some
of our educational programs
that we do, and some of those
impacts and some visions
for the future that we have.
This model is based on a Navajo
organizational process model,
and it's all about the
organization of information.
So you'll see this helped
us to organize our thoughts
for this presentation,
and figure out
how best to share our
collaboration with you all.
So we'll start here with
this ignition and Multiverse
mission.
OK, so the igniter.
This work started many years
ago with a collaboration
between our team at
the Space Sciences Lab
and the Indigenous
Education Organization
led by Nancy and David here.
And really, the focus on that
collaboration is relevant
learning comes from context.
So this idea of context
being very important,
we know here at Google that is
why you all exist as well, how
Google got to be so big.
So if you're interested
in connecting afterwards,
this is my contact information.
You can follow me on
Twitter for Laura Aurora.
So aurora is my expertise.
That's what I studied
in graduate school
and at the Space Sciences Lab.
Also, I'm the director of
our group called Multiverse,
and you can follow
that through Facebook.
We have a very
active Facebook page.
We also have a Twitter
feed, but it's not
quite as active at this point.
I am a senior fellow at
the Space Sciences Lab.
And our mission is
really at this point
to increase diversity in
earth and space science
through multicultural education.
So I'll be talking,
we'll be talking
a lot about that approach
and why do we do that.
So first, I wouldn't
be here today
if I didn't have the
support of my family.
I have two young children.
And so I just
wanted to shout out.
Thank you, family.
And I couldn't do this
work without the team
that I work with.
And many of you are here.
Can you raise your
hand, if you're
part of the Multiverse team?
So you'll see we're
sprinkled around.
We really feel at our heart
that diversity matters.
And we have a lot of discussion
about this word diversity
and what that means,
that it matters.
And hopefully you'll get a
sense of some of our thoughts
through this talk.
A quick way to say it is we
work with multiple communities
to acknowledge
their own universe,
and then to teach about
the universe of science.
So our name, Multiverse,
so multiverse
is actual physics
cosmology concept
that people are starting
to explore and understand.
And the idea is that we don't
just exist in this universe.
Well, we do, but there may be
other universities out there
with different laws of physics
and different things that
happen in those universes.
And for me, it's a good analogy
for how different communities
look at the world,
to think about,
when you step into a cult a
community with a culture very
different from yours,
what that feels like.
It's like going into
another universe, where
all the laws of
physics are different.
We have a lot of
undergraduates come to our lab,
and the lab has a
very specific culture.
And so we talked to
the undergrads about
what is that culture,
and what do they expect?
What should they expect to see
on a daily basis at our lab?
So that's one reason why
our name is Multiverse.
All right.
Nancy?
NANCY MARYBOY: Well,
good morning, everybody.
And I have to say, it's
very exciting for us
to be here at Google.
And we want to thank
Google for allowing
us to be part of
this presentation,
and also we so enjoy our work
with the Multiverse group
that we're almost like a family,
and this goes back many years.
So I am the president of
the indigenous Education
institute, which started
out in Bluff, Utah.
You can see the bluffs.
That was right
outside where I lived.
And now we're located in
Friday Harbor, Washington,
the beautiful San Juan Islands.
And you can find us actually on
Twitter and Facebook and Skype.
So we have a mission too, and
it has evolved over the years.
We're 25 years old.
We have had this
nonprofit, and it's great.
It's still going.
We have an all native board
from all around the world,
Maori from New Zealand,
Australia, Hawaii,
and we're virtual.
And we think this is great,
because we do everything
through telecommunications.
Our mission is to preserve,
protect, and apply
traditional
indigenous knowledge.
And what we're
doing is, we totally
believe we can find solutions
to problems, solutions
that are outside of
the box, solutions that
call on deep, ancient,
indigenous knowledge
from many different tribes.
And so what we do is we
like to form partnerships.
It's all about
collaboration as far
as we're concerned, but
collaborations with integrity,
where we totally respect the
viewpoint of the other entities
we're working with
and vice versa.
DAVID BEGAY: Equally excited
and honored to be here.
Nancy and I, we've been
working for a very long time.
Earlier, we were working
for a tribal college
called [INAUDIBLE] College
in Arizona and New Mexico.
And I was a dean,
academic dean there.
I became the vice
president, retired, and now
onto working with University
of Berkeley, and also faculty
at University of New Mexico.
I got recruited and also
faculty at Northern Arizona
University in the department
of physics and astronomy.
But that's where I'm at.
And I'm trying to
retire for good,
but I can't really
do it right now.
Things are just too excited.
That's why I'm here, I guess.
At Google, there's all
these opportunities.
But I guess I'm really
here to talk a little bit
about indigenous knowledge,
how it's different and similar
to mainstream knowledge as well.
And I'll just give you a few
examples in the slides that
are forthcoming.
NANCY MARYBOY: And
this is our team.
And some of you are
here in the room.
And I have two children
in that picture too,
a little older than
Laura's children.
And this is one we, like David
said, one of our great passions
is indigenous astronomy.
And we teach a
course we developed,
an online course, Introduction
to Indigenous Astronomy.
We teach it out of Northern
Arizona University.
And we are coming out of Dene
College, the Navajo tribal
college.
We worked there for a lot of
years/ I graduated from there.
I went to Stanford, so this
land is familiar to me.
And we got our Ph.Ds
in indigenous science.
You won't find too many people
that got that kind of a degree.
And it's a long story, and
we won't go into it here.
But anyway, here we
are in Washington DC.
We had just showed a
planetarium show we developed,
and we showed it at the
National Aerospace Museum,
and then we showed it for
a week at the National
Museum of the American Indian.
OK, this is really important.
We keep saying,
people might want
to know why we work together.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS: So we're
going to go through this.
You'll see this throughout
the whole presentation,
really, about why
we work together.
This is one of our projects,
which we'll talk about a little
more later.
But you'll see that this
project brought together people
from all sorts of different
tribes around the United
States, as well as
scientists, science educators,
and CEOs of museums.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about why it is we do that.
So here.
Do you want to
introduce this one?
NANCY MARYBOY: Yes, we want
to show you the collaborations
go way back.
So you might recognize the
fellow in the headdress
as Einstein.
He and his wife went out in 1931
to visit the Hopi reservation.
And what's really
interesting is books
have been written by
people like Benjamin Whorf
about how much of
Hopi, and we could also
say Navajo, ways of
knowing correlate
with relativity and
relational thinking.
So it's interesting
that he was out visiting
the Hopi in those days.
So that's an early
collaboration, LOL,
we put in for you all.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS: So one
of the long term visions
for our team is that science
and technology really becomes
a place where
everyone, when they
come to these institutions
and that work,
that they have a feeling
that their culture is there
as well, that they're not
walking into a culture that
is outside what they're used
to when they're at their homes.
So that is one of our long
term visions for this,
and we really feel
that one of the ways
to get there is by
working cross-culturally
with other people.
So as I said, the foundation
of our work in this field
was with David and Nancy.
And you'll see these books
that are available to you all.
They are also available online.
They were published
with your tax dollars.
So it's an NSF project.
So feel free to take
as many of those books
as you would like
and share them.
And you'll see the title is
"Collaboration With Integrity,"
and talks a little
bit about our journey
through some of this work.
All right.
So here's our next.
We're going to go to the
science universe and the Navajo
universe in the south.
OK, so we're here at
hosted by Making Science.
And of course, making
is very important.
And it's important
in our work as well.
So we're going to pass out
some materials for you all.
Maybe, David, you could say
something while I pass it out.
I'll hand it out to
some folks to pass.
DAVID BEGAY: People are always
looking around for a model
to organize plans,
and activities,
and to do planning,
strategic planning.
And they use different models.
And there's several really well
known models circulating out
there.
When it came to
our organization,
we ask each other that rather
than looking around or copying
other models or
using other models,
we wanted to use what was
indigenous to our land.
And so what we did is we went to
the elders, and we asked them,
is there an organization
that we can follow?
Is there one out there?
And they said, oh
yeah, it's out there.
It's right here in
the whole universe.
Where do we start?
And so, that's how we got around
to talking about the model.
And so we started to put
the process in there.
And the process provided the
structure and the organization.
So when you think
about it, there's
a very sophisticated, tremendous
order provided by nature.
It's an order.
It's real dynamic.
And so that's the
information that we used
to put these circles together.
And so there's more circles,
circles within circles.
Pretty soon you start to see
a fractal matrix, and circles,
and then within the circle there
are squares, and rectangles,
and triangles, and
they all work together.
And so we just took
a little piece,
and we wanted to use
indigenous knowledge
to provide this organization.
We wanted to
exemplify what we say.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS:
So you can tell
we've been working
together for a long time,
because I can just
hand David the mic.
So those of you who are here
now have these materials.
Hopefully you have scissors,
or someone near you
has a pair of scissors.
If not, we'll make sure the
scissors get over to you.
And then also, you have
some the cellophane bags
that we're going to use.
We also have some pipe
cleaners and some tape.
So the purpose of
this-- in making,
often you give people
materials, and they
get to figure out what
they want to do with them.
We will be talking
about these materials.
And if you would like to
make some handmade glasses
with filters, then that will
be appropriate to our talk.
So of course, you may
do whatever you would
like with these materials.
But we'll be talking about
seeing with multiple filters.
OK.
So we're going to
start with the sun.
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the physics
that I know about.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about the sun
and looking at the sun
from multiple perspectives.
So staying on this theme of
collaboration with integrity
and looking at the universe
from different cultural
perspectives.
So scientists also
use this notion
of looking at things with
different perspectives.
So I want to tell
you a little bit
about the sun when you do that.
So the sun, of course you
shouldn't be looking at the sun
directly without some filters
over your eyes, some good ones,
so that your eyes
stay protected.
But if you do either have the
sun projected onto a screen,
or you have good
filtered glasses,
then it will look like this.
It's white.
Sometimes, you'll
see spots on the sun.
If you look at the sun with
a Lyman-Alpha filter filter,
then it could look like this.
So it's red.
Lyman-Alpha is a
filter that filters out
a specific line coming
from the atom of hydrogen.
And when you basically
filter out everything
that you can see from
the sun except this line,
now you can start seeing some
really interesting features
on the sun.
So as you're making
your glasses,
you can hold up the
cellophane that you have there
and start to see what
disappears when you hold up
a color, what remains
there, what things change,
how d things change.
And it's the same
thing with the sun,
and we can learn a
lot about the sun.
So the atmosphere,
this atmosphere
that we're living
in, it blocks a lot
of the sunlight from the sun.
And a lot of the
sunlight we can't see,
so sunlight in the
infrared, sunlight
in the UV or ultraviolet.
And so if we want to study the
sun and learn more about it,
we actually have to get
away from the filter
of the atmosphere of Earth.
And so we do that by launching
satellites into space.
So where we are at the
Space Sciences Lab,
we create instruments to
put on these satellites,
and we work with NASA
and other industries
to launch these into
space and study the sun,
is one of the things we do.
So here you see the
stereo satellites.
There are two of them
with identical cameras
in order to get multiple
perspectives of the sun,
and actually see the
sun in stereo at times.
So when we do that, when we
get out of the atmosphere
and away into space,
and we look at the sun,
and we put these different
colored filters on our cameras
out in space, we can see that
the sun is this dynamic star.
It isn't this kind of
constant glowing ball of gas
that people think about,
but it is this dynamic, ever
changing, interesting object.
It's a star.
Of course, it's
our nearest star.
But then what we see when you're
looking at all these pictures,
you can see how with
a different filter,
you start to see these
features farther and further
away from what we call
the Earth's surface.
It's not a surface that
you could stand on.
It's not very dense at all.
But as you go farther away,
what scientists have learned
is that unlike a candle
flame or a fire, when
you go away from the candle
flame or fire, it gets cooler.
As you go towards fire,
it gets hotter and hotter.
The sun is a little
bit different.
If you start from Earth and
you go closer and closer
to the sun, it gets hotter
and hotter, of course.
But then, if you closer
in, closer to the surface,
it actually cools down again.
So it's this very strange
thing that we've discovered.
And we discovered
it first, in part,
from using filters to look
at the sun and see these.
And it turns out that
these features of the sun
are magnetically
driven, and that there's
some really complicated,
very cool plasma magnetism
interactions that
then heat up the sun.
So it's time to use
the filters you made.
So here are the
glasses I made before.
OK, so as an educator
and a scientist,
you can't worry about how
you look in this world.
There's too many more
important things to do.
So here I am.
And I see some of you
also in this room.
Those of you watching
remotely, hello.
You can't see everyone
else, but many people
have their glasses on.
It's awesome.
I hope you do too, if you
had any glasses nearby.
So when I look at you all
with my different glasses,
and I chose two
different colors,
then it changes how
I'm seeing the world.
I'm definitely going to
focus on different things.
And now I'm a little
bit visually impaired,
I have to say.
So not so comfortable.
And sometimes filters
aren't comfortable.
That is a truth.
So if you have your glasses,
or you have your filters up,
we brought these leis.
So maybe Nancy could
hold one of those up.
And, David, you could
hold one up as well.
So we believe that
working hard is
really important in
this work, but we also
believe that having
fun is super important.
So you can see.
We'll be talking about some
pretty abstract, deep concepts
in a minute here.
So if you can look at these
leis with different filters,
like if you hold up the
red one, then you can look
and see which colors
here do you actually see?
Or if you also want to
look at this screen,
does the red filter
block anything else out?
Does the blue filter
block things out?
Does this look different?
What do you learn about
that that you might not have
noticed with the new filters?
And so here's a picture
someone put together,
a scientist that I really like.
It's beautiful, and it
really gets across this idea
that when we look at the
sun in multiple filters,
we just find out way more
than we did when we just
look at it with one color.
NANCY MARYBOY: Yeah, I was
giving a talk in Seattle
to kids from all different
tribes, urban Indian kids.
And so I was making the
same point about filters.
And I was demonstrating with
three dimensional glasses,
3D glasses.
So if you look at both
eyes, you can see,
and you've got the appropriate
screen you're looking at,
like on TV, a 3D
channel, you're going
to see it in three dimensions.
If you close one
eye, you're just
going to see one dimension.
And that's why you
can't be a pilot
if you have just vision
in one eye, by the way.
But anyway, the
point we're making
is that we all filter our world
views, how we see the world.
We filter them through
our own world views.
We have our own tacit
infrastructure that
makes us see in a certain way.
And in order to really work
cross-culturally with success,
you need to learn how to do
put those tacit infrastructures
away and try to look
without the filters.
It's very hard to
do, because you'll
keep retaining a lot of what you
already have inherent in you.
But by making that
attempt, you we
will be able to get
into an area where
you can really deeply
listen to the other people
you're working with.
And then amazing things happen.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS:
So that is this analogy
that Nancy talked about.
So learning science
together through
different cultural filters.
So I want to talk just
briefly about when
we do this, what I found really
a fascinating and enriching
in my own science is I start
to think about what is science
in a way I never did before.
So of course, Earth and
space science is science.
It has the word science in it.
So we know that's science.
And this is the field
I'm comfortable in.
But a chemistry professor
once said to me,
cooking is chemistry.
It has all these
different reactions,
and he loved to come up
with new concoctions,
but thinking of it through
his chemistry lens.
So cooking could be considered
science by some people.
Some of the traditional, native
Hawaiian experts in Hawaii
that we work with,
they definitely
talk about traditional
ecological knowledge
being science.
So what you're seeing
here are some fish ponds
that they're restoring in the
ancient tradition in order
to keep their fish
production going strong.
So what is science?
If you've ever thought about
and wondered what is science,
there are actually
researchers out in the world
who research people
doing science,
and they write papers about it.
So it's very meta.
And then we're
trying to figure out
how to teach the nation about
science and about engineering.
And so the National
Academy put together
this a really
fantastic report called
"A Framework for K-12
Science Education
Practices, Cross Cutting
Concepts, and Core Ideas."
And it was actually led by a lot
of physicist here at Stanford.
I know we have some
Standford alums here.
And they went and looked
at all the research
on what is science?
What happens when
people do science?
So I'm going to tell you
a little just briefly.
Science fields have
their own language,
but the most common
language is probably math.
So math is a way to take
what nature is telling us
and turn into a language that we
can use to predict and explain.
So this is the equation that
I used in my Ph.D. thesis.
And it's a time dependent
electron transport equation.
So I wanted to show some quotes
from that, from that report.
So I'm going to just read these.
Although some kinds of
culturally valued knowledge
and practices, including
spiritual and mystical thought,
are at odds with
science, a growing body
of published research shows that
some of the knowledge derived
from varied cultures
and contexts
provides valid and consistent
scientific interpretations.
So you'll see some
of that today.
Although any real system
smaller than the entire universe
interacts and is dependent
on other external systems.
So this technology that
everything's interconnected,
it is often useful to
conceptually isolate
a single system for study.
So here I'm showing
our atmosphere
that goes out into space.
And typically, we'll take
one layer of atmosphere
and study it really carefully.
But there are these interactions
that happen between the layers.
We know scientists and engineers
investigate and observe
the world with
essentially two goals,
to systematically
describe the world
and to develop and test
theories and explanations of how
the world works.
So here I am showing some
of our teachers in Nevada
that we work with,
and there we have
buried a magnetometer, which
is an instrument to study
Earth's magnetic fields.
And the teachers actually
use this with their students
to understand how the Earth's
magnetism is changing.
Human beings are part of and
dependent on the natural world.
And the new technologies enable
new scientific investigations,
allowing scientists
to probe realms
and handle quantities of
data previously inaccessible
to them.
So here's my son and his friend.
I got permission from
his friend's mom,
today, to use this picture.
And they are part of the world.
We're out hiking, and they
are a part of the trees
and everything around them.
And then at the same
time, we're developing
these amazing technologies.
This is our stardust
mission that we ran out
of Space Sciences Lab.
And they went up and
captured all this stardust,
and then had people
in the public
actually analyze
that data online.
And that was new
technology to figure out
how to do that kind of
citizen science project
with massive amounts of data.
So what I'm trying
to show you here
is not only what is science,
but that different sciences
each have their own culture.
They have their own language.
They have their own values.
They have their own world views.
I'm not sure they
have their own foods.
I'm not sure physicists eat any
differently than ecologists,
but maybe someone
has studied that.
So this takes us to
the Navajo universe.
What is that universe like?
DAVID BEGAY: This
isn't another planet
or somewhere in the universe.
This is just right here.
When I talk to other indigenous
people, Hopis that live next
to our land, they have
a similar worldview,
and they're going to depict
how they look at the world.
And then there are other people
that National Geographic,
some pictures of worldviews
of the Maya people,
and Incas, and other indigenous
people around the world.
So they look at the
worldview different.
And I think aside from
thinking in this way,
I was raised with this
culture and consciousness.
And so this is, I guess,
if you call it a box,
this would be my box.
And I have to think
outside that box
to think through the
Euro-American box.
And so whenever
I went to school,
when I went to the university,
I had to think outside this box
into this other box in order
to process information.
And also coming outside
that box worldview,
even furthermore, I had to
drop a lot of my worldview,
including what Laura was
talking about, spirituality.
That's a big part of the native
consciousness and worldview,
deep culture.
That's where the deep
knowledge was at.
And so I had to
get away from that
and just think science as
science, talk that language
and imitate what
other people say,
and be pure scientist in order
to survive in that laboratory
and you know all the
math like everybody else.
But this is pretty
much the worldview
from which I come from.
And just a little
explanation-- Navajos,
they believe that a long,
long, long time ago, they
don't put numbers
on it, they say
that the evolution of
all life processes,
the original energy
was light, they say.
Light evolved.
And the formation of life
goes way, way, way back.
Very similar to the
Big Bang, I think.
And so from that evolved
all life in different forms.
So the whole universe,
we have our own way
of organizing our
constellations.
And it's circular.
It starts with the
North Star, and it's
counterclockwise as observed.
And so the constellation
organization
is a sort of spiral
counter clockwise.
That's how we would
talk about it.
Once you're an astronomer,
you can jump around and say,
there's Orion.
There's Pleiades.
There's Scorpius.
But when you talk about
our constellation,
you have to follow the
order, a certain way
of talking about it.
There's the winter
constellation,
summer constellation.
And some expand
across time and space.
And pretty soon, we're going to
show one of the constellations.
They're pretty big.
You just can't say there it is.
It expands across
time and space.
They're pretty big.
So it's a different way
of looking at the world
and talking about
constellations.
There's teachings
in all of them.
And so I guess I can go on, and
on, and on, and on about this.
But a lot of the
words that we use,
I think that really
makes a big difference.
For example, in star,
we say [? setsuyo, ?]
which translated in English
is "my ancient relation
from which I came."
That's different from
saying the word star.
Star had a different definition.
If you say, my ancient
relation, my ancient,
going back way in
time, I'm related.
That's where I come
from, from which I came.
I am of that.
I think science
says, we're stardust.
I think Native Americans
are saying the same thing
in so many words.
So this is
information, knowledge,
that makes you think,
a little information
on the language, how it's
differently constructed.
NANCY MARYBOY: Yeah,
we could mention
that what we usually have
to do when we talk with,
when we present with
Western scientists
or do workshops or things,
most people have all
gone to grade school,
high school, and college
in the Western sense.
And so we all share in this
room those Western views,
but most people,
unless they're native,
don't know the native education.
And in a lot of cases back
home, on the Navajo reservation,
our kids aren't getting
the Navajo side of things,
unless their parents are really
making an effort to transmit
the knowledge and the language.
And so one of our emissions
from IEI and what we do
is to create more
awareness of the Navajo,
or Cherokee, or Lakota
knowledge to bring it up
to a parity with
Western so then we
can start having
a real dialogue.
But we usually have to talk
somewhat about the native side
of things first, just
so people understand
what another paradigm or another
worldview could look like.
One of the things
that's really important
is that the traditional
knowledge, it
comes from nature, but
it's talked about in terms
of ceremony, and the
elders are very respected
for their knowledge.
And so everything we
did in our research,
we'd go back and double,
triple check it with elders,
and make sure that it was
what they wanted us to say.
So that's something.
These are couple little
differences that we're just
going to examine.
Another one is,
it's very important
the idea of interrelationships,
interdependencies
of everything.
And so this knowledge emerges
from very careful observations
of the Earth and sky.
And so I can't tell you how
many nights David and I went out
for years, and years,
and years, looking
at Navajo constellations and
the patterns of the stars.
Because everything we were
researching wasn't in books.
And you couldn't go to a
library and just look it up.
You couldn't go to some
expert and find out.
We wrote a book on
Navajo astronomy,
of which we did bring one
copy here to show you,
which was an attempt to give
back to Navajo students what is
somewhat lost in the culture.
But the careful observation
comes from the language.
And so native languages
are so incredibly precise.
You've probably
heard this before
that Alaskans have all
these different word
ways to describe snow.
And Navajo do too.
But they are so precise.
They are probably
the epitome of what
a scientific language could
be if it wasn't in English.
OK.
OK, another one
that's very important
is the concept of
reciprocal relationships.
Everything's in a relationship.
We are in relationships.
We have family.
We have clans.
We have cities.
We have states.
We have this Earth we live on.
We're in the solar system.
We go out to the local group.
It goes on and on, but it's
all in terms of relationships.
And if you go into a
Navajo school, for example,
or where we worked, people have
on their door their four clans.
And then they will
know how to relate
to a professor, or a student.
And that student could
be your grandmother.
And then you treat them as
if they're your grandmother.
This is clan relationships.
Now, it has nothing
to do with age.
So relationships are
really important.
And the whole example
of reciprocity--
you do something for
somebody or something,
and something comes back to you.
It's all a balance.
And so that kind of
thing is so lacking
in the dominant
societies of this world
today that these
are things we think
that knowing more of the native
of ways could bring to science,
or even bring to something like
Google, a new way of looking
at old things.
And the concept of
stewardship-- when
we started working with NASA,
it stunned some of them,
because they had never thought
of stewarding the Earth,
taking care of the Earth.
It was more like, let's
go out and explore.
And since we worked with
them over the years,
we've seen a real turn now.
And there are wonderful
people, and some of them
are in this room, who
are really thinking
in terms of taking
care of the Earth,
and leaving something
for future generations.
And you can see the way
the world is going so
fast in this other direction.
These kind of concepts, we
have a real strong belief
that it can help to know
some of these things.
DAVID BEGAY: I think when you
go to these native communities,
some native people, they
believe that what we have here
is really borrowed.
It's from the future generation,
seven generations out.
All of if what we have
here is being borrowed.
And so what we do here is going
to affect the generation that's
forthcoming.
And so we're really living here
on borrowed time and resources.
It doesn't belong
to this generation.
It belongs to our
feature generations,
and we should take care of it.
I think that kind of mentality
and really believing in that,
and really living
that life, that's
different from just
thinking about it, I think.
NANCY MARYBOY: OK,
another one is,
if you're doing research,
any kind of science,
like native science,
the validation is not
in peer reviewed journals.
It's not in the having
your book published.
It comes from the community.
Those are the people
whose validation
we needed for the work we did.
And then we could take it
out into the wider world.
But it's true of
indigenous communities,
a lot of these things are
true of indigenous communities
all over the world,
but whoever's
going to put that
stamp of approval on it
is going to be an
elder or community
leader or [INAUDIBLE] person.
This one's a real
controversial thing today.
And it's really important.
But a lot of native
knowledge is protected,
and it always has been.
But a lot of it has
also been misused
by pharmaceutical
companies and people that
will learn about the use
of a plant, then go out
and harvest all the rest
of them there ever were,
like goldenrod, for example.
And so the concept of using
a plant, which is really
your relative, in the
native way of thinking,
using it for personal
gain or corporate gain,
it doesn't exist in
the native world.
And so this is why there's
some real controversies
about indigenous intellectual
property rights, where
the community is holding
the knowledge, and patents,
like in the United States, where
individuals hold the knowledge.
So if you want to work with
native communities and partner
with them, you have to know
some of these protocols.
You want to know
and abide by them.
And I'm just telling
you this because it's
a hot topic in indigenous
communities today.
Nothing could be more
important than the language.
And we're talking
in English today,
which is great, because we
can all understand each other.
But just like, I
guess, to some extent
English defines an
American worldview, Navajo,
or any native language, really
defines the native worldview.
And so when you hear of
language disappearing
at a very fast rate today, and a
tribe will have a last speaker,
not only does that
person pass away,
not only does the knowledge
of that language pass away,
but all that millennia
knowledge that goes with it.
And like I said, these
are very precise languages
that would be interesting--
I mean, scientists don't know
them, because who could
speak Navajo, and Lakota,
and Cherokee, and Inuit,
and all these languages.
But there is just an
incredible science that
resides within these languages.
So I'll give you an example.
The reason we have that
road up there is in Navajo,
all these languages,
all of them, we think,
are languages of process
and relationship.
And when a person looks at
English, or French, or Spanish,
they consider them very
static relationships.
And if you think back, and
when you all were in school,
and you learned French
or Spanish, for example,
probably the first
word you learned
was chair, and table, and door.
They're all nouns.
But in the native languages,
they are very dynamic words,
and they can be
created as you talk.
David's just an
excellent speaker.
He can make up things and talk
within an order in Navajo,
and you just could be amazed.
But somebody counted
this up in Navajo.
We have one word in
English called go.
Navajo has 200,000
ways to say go.
It's all about process.
It's all about a
movement, a world that's
in constant movement, a universe
that's in constant movement.
I think quantum physicists
talk about this too,
that dynamic movement
of the universe.
But that's why it's so important
for more diverse languages
to stay on this Earth,
because the knowledge that's
embedded in them are
specific to a place.
And it's just very deep
knowledge of that place.
DAVID BEGAY: Laura
wanted me to use some
of our words to explain this.
And so we've got this
off Google and got it up
here on the screen now.
Our word for tornado,
we call it niyoltsoh.
It talks about that
cyclonic action,
nyoltsoh, that cyclonic action.
It's a creation by the sun.
You say, johonaa ei,
meaning, the sun.
It's creation.
It comes from the sun,
interaction with the Earth
down here.
That's what it is.
When you see the tornado,
you see the sun's activity
and the sun's energy at work.
There's no one
name for a tornado.
It's the sun's energy at work.
And so with that, when a
tornado comes into being,
[SPEAKING NAVAJO]
What comes into being is
also the gravity, the Earth's
gravity, and the gravity.
It's male and female.
It comes down, and
then it goes back up.
Now you see it.
Now you don't.
And then the energy
[INAUDIBLE] that lightning.
Male energy and
the female energy.
It's inherent in nature, as
it's inherent in a tornado
at a given time.
It's fuel that
provides the energy.
They say, [SPEAKING NAVAJO].
It comes into being.
So it's not the one thing.
It's not one thing.
It's all the interaction.
It's nature.
It works as one system.
And so in our
language, if we were
to talk about, for
example, gravity,
you have to talk about
the unity of all things.
In the Western world,
you can take gravity,
and you can talk about gravity
using Einstein's definition,
or the [INAUDIBLE]
and we can even
use math to talk about gravity.
In the Native
American world, you
have to use the totality
of all these relationships.
Gravity does not
happen by numbers.
Gravity is in the
whole universe acting.
The same thing
here, the tornado,
it's the whole universe acting.
It's a different kind of
science, a different way
of looking at things.
So it's all described
through that motion
that Nancy was talking about.
It's a verb-based language.
English, it's different,
a different construction.
So what you start to
see is a different way
of looking at things.
It's not the same.
It's a different way.
I guess, looking at all the
diversity of how people think,
I think that's what
it is needed, I think.
The more worldview,
the more ways
of looking at the
different world,
I think the more intelligent
people can become,
the more rich your thought
process could be, I think.
NANCY MARYBOY: Yeah,
this one [INAUDIBLE]
because we are talking about
integrity, collaboration,
diversity, and growth.
And this was used in the
cover of "Dimension Magazine"
for Aztec, the coyote,
throwing up the stars.
It's a Navajo story of how
the stars were created.
And the coyote is
a trickster figure,
who throws a wrench
into everything.
But he's also very smart,
and he has a big part
throughout all of Navajo
history and cosmology.
It's also a way of
talking-- if you
want to go to another level--
it's a way to talk about chaos
theory and then complexity
theory, how the chaos is
contained by complexity.
And so you can go very
deeply into these subjects.
We used some quantum
physics concepts
for some of the work
we did, just because it
helped us find English
works to explain what
we were trying to talk about.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS:
OK, so we were just
talking about science universe
and the Navajo universe.
So hopefully you
got a sense of how
those two worldviews and the
way we think about things
are very different.
We're going to talk next
about the programming
that we actually create from
these different worldviews
for children,
undergraduates, for adults,
educators around the US.
So I'm going to just
pretty quickly go
through some of these.
I'm not going to give
you too many details.
I just want to kind
of wet your appetite.
I know we're near
the end of our hour.
So here we have found some
youth-- I think one of them
is in the room today-- learning
how to program, computer
software programming,
in order to bring NASA
data into the phones with
these Google Cardboard boxes,
so that kids can learn
more about the environment
around them.
And if you want to
know more about that,
you can ask our guest over here.
So this is one of our programs.
It's one of our high
school programs.
And the other thing I wanted
to mention about high school
programs and our Team
Multiverse runs right now
the Bay Area Teen
Science Organization,
which is a collaboration of
organizations around the Bay
Area to support teens and
help them learn science.
So this is one of the examples
of the teen programs happening
around the Bay Area.
But if you are interested in
that kind of work in the Bay
Area, then look for the Bay
Area Teen Science Listserv,
and you can sign up and
learn more about that.
We also really support
girls in science.
We work with Girls Inc
and also Girl Scouts.
This is a picture of some
after school providers
learning about
electromagnetic spectrum,
and doing it in a way
appropriate for their audience,
for the girls in their program.
So these girls are typically in
middle school and high school.
This program that
we ran was called
Five Stars, because it
was to bring generations
from elementary grades, middle
school grades, undergraduates,
graduate students,
and scientists,
to have them all interact
in a meaningful way
in after school programs to
learn about space science.
We also work with
Lick Observatory.
Part of why we're
here at Google today
is our collaboration with
Alex Filippenko and the Lick
Observatory.
We have a graduate
student here from there,
who's been doing research
up at Lick Observatory.
We also run a teacher workshop,
where teachers actually observe
the night sky using telescopes.
And then they download their
data and analyze that data,
so that they know what is
the scientific process like.
And that's really to
help one of our visions
for the world, which is that
people develop and sustain
the ability to think critically
using observation evidence.
It's really important
to all of us.
This is a picture from
energy of the sun.
We worked with also teachers to
teach them about electricity,
and magnetism, and
the dynamic sun
that I was showing
you about earlier.
So here they are making,
basically with solar panels.
And that's been a
very successful model.
Here are our undergraduates
that come and do
research projects with our lab.
So we have many, many different
labs within our space sciences
lab.
And we have undergrads come up
and do research in those labs
to support the research
being done there.
And this is our
last year's cadre.
And then we have some
of the undergrads
from this year here too.
And a lot of these
undergrads come
from community colleges
in the Bay Area,
or around the United States.
So a lot of time, they're
saving money in order
to get into the state schools.
But this way they can launch
their career in sometimes
a limited resource
environment, and then
come into the system,
the pipeline--
I guess they would use that
word-- towards science.
So we're here to support them
and their different worldviews.
Here, where we do work
with NASA satellites,
our lab works a lot with that.
So here Nancy, Nancy Mary.
I guess you all
see him over here.
Here, Nancy and I are doing a
webcast from the Maven launch.
So Maven launched
in November 2013
from the cape down in Florida.
And we were there
doing a live webcast
to some of these schools
with Navajo kids.
And so we talked about some of
these concepts at the launch.
And then they got to see
the launch afterwards.
And then this is an
example of a curriculum
we're developing to bring these
two worldviews for students.
So students who are
Navajo, or Caucasian,
and I think Hispanic as
well, are in these classes
so that you can
go into your class
and you see a little
piece of your culture
somewhere along the curriculum,
so you don't feel so much
like, where am I in this,
which I think a lot of people,
if they're not from the dominant
culture, that's how they feel.
I certainly did,
going through school.
So this is an example
of some curriculum
that we're working in
collaboration on, David, Nancy,
and I, and some
teachers as well.
So I'm going to pass this.
NANCY MARYBOY:
OK, in this one, I
think we might have mentioned.
We built a planetarium show.
We were funded by NASA.
And for five years,
we've been working on it.
It's done now, and
we're going to be
putting it out and selling it.
We worked with this Brian
Mendez from Multiverse.
And we did the Navajo part,
and he did the Western part.
And so it's a series of modules
of Navajo astronomy and then
comparative Western astronomy.
So if you're looking
at Orion and talking
about Orion in Navajo
terms, and then
you could be talking about it as
what it is in Greek mythology,
and as a birthplace for stars.
And we worked with
Hubble Telescope people
to show what was
beyond, if you looked
in the direction of a
Navajo constellation,
what else was out there that
could be seen by telescope?
And so we're just
about done with a book
now on it explaining
about Navajo astronomy
and the constellations.
And so we take it around.
We have a portable
planetarium, and we take it
around to different museums
and different schools.
And right, now
we're developing--
it's a step backwards.
We're really developing
it back into a flat screen
show from the dome
360 degree show,
so that teachers that
don't have access
to a portable
planetarium, or even
could go to a planetarium,
and lots of people
out in rural areas
or on reservations,
so that they can show
it on a big flat screen.
So it's almost like a step
backward in technology,
but we noticed that a lot of
the big developers of these dome
shows are also stepping
back and starting
to make it more accessible.
We also have a project called
the Cosmic Serpent that we
had for about four years.
And we worked with about,
oh, maybe 43 museums, mostly
science centers, Exploratorium
was one here in this area.
And we worked with about 160,
70 different professionals.
It was professional development
for a week long workshop
to talk about the kind of things
we're talking about today,
what are native ways of knowing,
what are Western science ways?
How can they come together?
How can they enhance each other?
What are the
pitfalls, challenges,
and the great expectations that
can come out of some of this?
So the fellow up there with
his hand up in the air, Kaimana
Barcarse, he's been one of
the key people on the Hawaiian
around the world voyages, where
they're taking Hawaiian canoes,
and they have rediscovered
how to navigate by the stars,
and by the waves,
and by the birds,
and by the fish, and old,
traditional ways of navigation.
And they're actually taking one
of the canoes around the world
as we speak.
It's just a phenomenal thing.
So he's talking
about the compass
and how they do
their navigation.
And so it all comes
back to observation
of what's around you,
and where you want go.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS: So
this is another project.
When we did Cosmic Serpent,
we had educators come together
into week long workshops
away from their institutions.
And many went back and were
successful in implementing
programs built on the
relationships they had built
at these museums,
at these workshops
with their native colleagues,
or with their science education
colleagues.
But some went back to their
institutions and said,
we have no support for this
work at our institution.
And we're so excited about it.
We understand what
you've taught us,
but we really need some help
working with the culture
within our institution itself.
So this was NSF.
Is is.
We still have it going.
It's a collaboration
between IEI and Multiverse,
but also the Imiloa
Astronomy Center over on Hilo
on the big island of Hawaii.
And Ka'iu Kimura
is our other co-PI,
so you can imagine
her sitting here.
So what we did is we
chose three museums that
were ready for this.
So their CEOs were ready.
They said, yes, please.
We'd like to work with our
local native communities.
So those were Oregan Museum of
Science and Industry, Arizona
sonora Desert Museum, and
Durango Discovery Museum.
And we worked with
those three museums
to do a nine month residency.
So our team went in
and worked with them
very intensely for nine months.
Sometimes, at a
week at a time, we'd
be there, and have
the whole museum
open to learning about
some of these ideas,
and how can we talk about
environmental change, not only
from the ecosystem
perspective but also
from the indigenous perspective?
And here we are in Mauna Kea.
All right, so our
last few minutes,
we're going to show
a few impacts here.
all our programs are
evaluated externally.
So this is one of our external
evaluators, Jill Stein.
She's fabulous.
And they show whether
or not we're successful.
And for the most part,
we've been very successful
meeting our goals
and objectives.
Here's one of our teen
programs, Carmen Zheng,
She's now an astrophysicist.
She's back there.
She's not an astrophysicist yet.
She's an undergrad
at UC Berkeley.
But when we first met, her she
was in 10th grade, I think.
10th grade.
And she's back here
by the computer.
And she wrote a
testimony for us.
And she said, with every
solar powered fountain
and other exhibit I
built, presentation about
auroras I made, and even riding
a train for the first time
to travel to another state
to see a solar eclipse,
I knew my Multiverse
internship program had not only
rekindled a passion, but
it had reopened my window
to the stars.
I discovered my future.
And sure enough, she
got into UC Berkeley,
and she's now actually,
I think, a sophomore
in the astronomy
department at UC Berkeley.
We work with these
teachers as I showed you.
I will use Eye on
the Sky majorly
in constructing a national, next
generation science standards
aligned unit on astronomy.
Thank you.
This was extraordinarily
high quality training.
Truly fun activities
are easy to follow.
So the other one was
my teen [INAUDIBLE],
this Ruth [? Paliorani ?]
was reading that.
I will wait to retire until
after funding for this NASA
magnetometer program has ended.
Vic [? Trautman, ?] he
has still not retired.
He's like five years
past retirement,
but he's still hanging
on strong, because we
keep getting funding for it.
And we'll talk a little bit
about funding and funding
possibilities.
NANCY MARYBOY: End of our hour.
Yeah, we've had a
lot of good comments.
You might wonder how
the evaluation came out
with the native students
seeing it, the Navajo Sky Show.
And they were very excited.
Most of them didn't know
they had an astronomy.
And we're very excited about it.
Teachers are very
excited about it,
because it gives them
another curriculum to teach.
There's a protocol that
goes with it that you only
tell these kinds of star
stories in the winter.
So what we have
done is to encourage
people that use our materials
to use them more in the winter.
So we've gotten some
very encouraging,
wonderful evaluations.
And we've gotten a lot of
support from the Navajo Nation
on this too.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS:
But this is just one
of our participants in our
Cosmic Serpent workshop,
just talking about how it went.
And then here, I think,
this is Larry Campbell.
He's a tribal historic
preservation officer
in the Swinomish Indian tribe
that's up in Washington state.
I really like this last part.
It is, the work we're
doing is an important part
of the overall strategy to
bring people together rather
than divide us by leaving out
crucial voices in this effort.
So you see, today, we
did this talk together,
because I can't speak
for David and Nancy.
I learned so much from them.
I can speak from my own Western
European American culture.
And I can speak for
my scientific culture,
but I can't speak from
the Navajo culture.
I don't know it.
I don't know that knowledge.
And I know some things, but
still, it's not mine to share.
NANCY MARYBOY: Let me
just say one thing.
Larry Campbell's on our
board, and what I just
wanted to tell you is that
as a result of the Cosmic
Serpent, he and a young
Ph.D. Student-- I mean,
she's got her Ph.D-- they're
doing about a research project
in a Swinomish reservation.
And it's on toxins
in the shellfish
there that are part of
their traditional foods.
It's funded by NSF now,
and so this is all growing.
And he's quitting his job as
tribal historic preservation
officer and being a partner
with the Jamie Donatudo,
the Ph.D. candidate.
So it's really fun seeing
even on the native side
and the non-native
side, how this
is opening up and spreading,
and people are growing,
and going on to new projects
with this collaboration
as their igniter.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS: OK, so
that's the end of our talk.
Are there any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
So as a science fiction
enthusiast, and I too
read so much science
fiction growing up,
it really inspired me,
so the question, then,
is there maybe an analogy
between our reading
of science fiction
and being inspired
by science and storytelling
in the native communities
and that inspiration
towards science?
Did I get that right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NANCY MARYBOY: Well, we can
both try to answer that.
For one thing, storytelling, the
story goes directly to a point.
And so you can get a point
across through a story
that you might not
be able to get across
with a long,
lengthy explanation.
And that painting we have of the
coyote throwing up the stars,
Astec, which is the Association
of Science and Technology
Centers, asked us to write an
article, our collaboration,
about the value of
storytelling and science.
And that was the focal
point of the whole issue.
And they put that on the cover.
And that one day I was
walking around the Astec area,
and they said, and I spotted
it, and the whole thing had
been translated into Chinese.
We were trying to find a
picture of that for this,
but we couldn't find it in time.
So it was like the coyote
was throwing it up,
and everything in the
magazine, including the name,
was in Chinese.
But we do know that
Navajos themselves
are getting really excited.
So they've done
I've they've done
several really cool little
films on Navajos going to Mars
and including part
of the culture in it.
And when Laura said we're going
to be working with Mars now,
and I thought, geez, I
don't know much about Mars.
So I started reading these
science fiction books
by Ben Bova.
And the hero is a
Navajo astronaut.
So there's a whole spin-off on
these kinds of things going on.
And it's really fun and
engages Navajo students,
and other cultures' students,
and just about anybody,
because it shows
that everybody's
fascinated by space.
That's why David
and I do this, what
we do with Navajo astronomy.
It's a way in for kids, because
they love space so much.
And we've all grown
up in generations
that are really
fascinated by space,
and "Star Wars", and all that.
So it really is a
great way to go in,
and stories are a wonderful way.
And that's how the Navajo
stories, transmitted
in the winter, in the houses,
and they would act out
the stories with song and
with animal songs that
described the animal
voices, and all of this.
That was how, through story,
and they sing about these things
too, that was how this
knowledge was passed down.
So it's pretty
natural that now it's
going into films and
all these other ways.
DAVID BEGAY: Yeah, I think
that a lot of these stories
are very comical
at the same time.
There's one story that people
refer to as in-law stories.
The mother-in-law
and the son-in-law
shouldn't see each other.
There's always conflicts and
complications that can happen.
And anyway, it's a story.
Everybody laughs,
and the teaching
that comes from this story
is that you will never
see Orion and Scorpius in
the sky at the same time,
because they're at different
places during the season.
You will never see it in
the sky at the same time.
And so that's the teaching.
So on the one hand, it's a
story everybody laughs about.
But out of that story
is these constellations,
you will never see it.
That's real observational
information.
NANCY MARYBOY: Yeah, and one
more thing about these stories.
The Navajo constellations
were put up there
with stories and values
on how to live a really
proper and orderly life.
And then when you
start comparing
the Greeks' constellations,
which were about incest,
and violence, and murder,
they're really wild.
So they used their astronomy
for different reasons,
and Navajos used theirs
for different reasons.
But it's really about teaching.
All the stars, all the
constellations, the sun,
and the moon have
great teaching values.
And those kinds of things
are pretty known all
around reservations today.
So it's just a different
use of stars and stories.
DR. LAURA PETICOLAS:
It reminds me
when you were
saying that too, we
work with some native youth,
who are either a high schooler
or are in college.
And one of them, Kyle
Swimmer, he was talking.
So he was told these teaching,
some of his own teachings.
He's a Laguna Pueblo.
And he was taught some of
these teachings, some teachings
and stories about the sun and
how it moves on the horizon.
And he said once--
he was talking to us
and he said, he would
spend part of our projects,
and we'd talk a lot about
the sun, because we're
solar scientists, and
aurora scientists,
and so we were
talking about the sun
and how it comes up in
different places every day
around the seasons,
and where it does,
and the distance between
the rising of the sun.
And he looked at
us and he said--
[GASP]
I understand the story.
So they had talked about how the
sun moves faster in the summer,
I think, during the equinoxes
than in the solstices.
And he realized now
that what they meant
is that when it's coming up, it
comes up closer to each other.
And so he could put this story
that had this knowledge in it
to the physics and
the observation
from the Western
teachings as well.
So he talks a lot about how
these two teachings help
him to understand the world.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so let's
thank our guests, Laura, David,
and Mary.